es oficial después de varias amenazas
estados unidos y reino unido han vetado
la importación de gas petróleo y carbón
de rusia que aplicará a partir de
finales de 2022 un redoble de sanciones
que tendrá consecuencias en los mercados
mundiales
este es un paso que estamos dando para
infligir más dolor a putin pero también
habrá un costo aquí en eeuu dije que
sería sincero con el pueblo
estadounidense desde el principio y
cuando hablé por primera vez de esto
dije que defender la libertad nos va a
costar
y es que esta es una medida arriesgada
para castigar a rusia ya que el país
proporcionó más de 700 mil barriles de
crudo a eeuu el año pasado debido al
conflicto y otras variables como la alta
inflación ahora el precio de la gasolina
en el país norteamericano ha batido un
récord 4,1 dólares el galón un precio
que no alcanzaba desde la crisis de 2008
está exageradamente caro cada día más
caro especialmente para los estudiantes
como cada vez es más difícil
permitírselo vamos a tener que compartir
auto
pero europa decidió no sumarse a estas
sanciones ya que el continente es muy
dependiente del gas y del petróleo ruso
allí los efectos de la guerra ya se
están empezando a sentir con el precio
de la energía disparado a 345 euros el
gas por megavatio la hora la unión
europea podría imponer sanciones
energéticas a rusia pero sufrirían
acordemente para los europeos la parte
del pastel energético de rusia es mucho
mayor que aquí en eeuu nosotros estamos
cerca de la independencia energética
pero la eurozona no está ni de lejos a
pesar de las consecuencias globales
desde estados unidos aseguran que
occidente no financiará la guerra de
rusia y que el gasoducto nord stream 2
de rusia alemán ya está muerto